well the discovery children's museum is
the only children's museum in las vegas
and for 31 years they continue to
educate our youth in a fun way so today
we are talking all things science and
summer and joining us is gordy driver
gordy how are you doing well how are you
doing good i feel a little underdressed
but you're right you're the professional
here so before we start playing with
everything because i'm really excited
about this let's talk about what the
museum has planned for the summer you
guys have some fun things coming up
that's right so on june 6th we've got
our
golf open that is happening at uh
reflection bay
on june 6th and which please go check it
out over the summer we've also got our
summer camp programs that are happening
throughout the entire way they are
almost filled so please make sure you
sign up if you want to join those
programs other than that it's just
another fun day at the museum come on by
enjoy
a local discount if you are a las vegas
native come on by and we'll be happy to
have you well thanks for bringing the
museum to us here today
to play around so what are we starting
with so we've got quite a few things
right here i know we got so much time
today but we're going to be
demonstrating our oscillating uh
experiment here so this is what we call
an oscillating stoplight so as you may
see it's just colorless water that we've
got right here but we're going to add a
few ingredients to this water today
first we got some dextrose which for any
of you who know out there at home this
is just going to be a base of sugar and
i'll go ahead and add that sugar right
in now should i prepare for anything too
oh nothing will nothing will explode
no i will not i would not do that to you
no so what we got here is we got that
mixing in right now okay we're gonna go
ahead and add some uh very special fluid
right here this is sodium hydroxide
sodium hydroxide is naturally caustic to
the skin so i've got these fancy gloves
right here and you'll be safe jillian
don't worry because that's all it's
going to do is go right here in our
flask just like that so what i'm going
to do now
i'm actually going to pop this uh lid
back on give it a nice little shake you
can see right there okay and it's
actually going to feel if you want to
put your hand right there you can
actually feel it's kind of warm right
now yes just kind of let's just let know
that the chemical reaction is occurring
okay um so what we're going to do is
we're going to add our last ingredient
right here it's a little bit of a milky
it's going to turn transparent in a
second we're going to add some of this
blue dye right here this is actually uh
indigo carmine indigo carmite is the
same dye that you use in your blue jeans
so we're going to go ahead and add some
of this ingo carmine right here in our
idea what's about to happen i'm really
excited to see it it's quite all right
bill nye the science guy
i'm gonna name you now we usually just
do this experiment for our wizard week
that happens annually and so we like to
play this as a potion per se because of
its very dramatic color scheme so we're
gonna go ahead and add that and you can
see it has that very bright yellow
because we saw that it normally is blue
so we're going to go ahead
take this and we're going to stir it
around just a little bit more okay and
you can see it actually starts is that
yellow color
and then we're going to go ahead and
shake it just a little bit more i'm so
amazed right now i was expecting this to
be blue yeah and so what's gonna happen
is as those molecules are breaking down
well uh it'll get it's gonna change
colors and we'll go ahead and actually
review that in just a second it's gonna
take about 30 seconds or so okay we're
about to wrap up here but i want you to
tell me really quickly because i need to
know what this is like this right over
here this is a tornado generated built
at the
museum today i'm talking way too fast
it's very exciting so what we got here
is hypersonic foggers that are creating
a water vapor which is having the vapors
twirl on up through a uh in-house
ventilation fan it's creating a vortex
that is going to be fun for kids to
interact with you can stick your hand
right there and we'll just perform if
you like to try you're welcome okay i
would love to try i mean i've lived in
las vegas my whole life i've never seen
a real tornado so this is about as close
as i'm getting to it oh my gosh this is
so so much fun i know you have a 4d
printer going on over here too but yeah
we do have to wrap up so we'll continue
to post everything on social media yes
be sure to go check out the discovery
children's museum you can take part in
fun things like this all the time so
thank you so much thank you so much
jillian all right jc i'll send it over
to you that looks like a lot of